I think first we we try to make a
distinction between national culture and
company culture I mean when we go to
China to India to Canada to Brazil to
Belgium to Germany to Argentina of
course they each country has a different
country culture and that's great that's
why we travel that's why during
vacations we try to go to different
places to experience of those dif
different cultures so that is great on
the other hand what we say is that if
you want to join us you have to
understand that we are one company one
culture and when you look at our culture
it's so much about common sense it's so
much about what a good athlete would do
to perform it's so much what a good
student would do to perform so it's a
performance high performance culture
that we're trying to build here so I've
met people in the last 10 years we've
we've been through five or six business
combinations and you're in all those
business combinations I often ask the
question what is different between our
company and this company we're merging
with again not right or wrong but what's
different and the only thing it could
buy put put my fingers on was what we
call the dream people culture if you
have people that I aspire to build
something that is out of the ordinary
that's something that's in class that
you can be both part off and proud of I
think that's already a very good start
if because of that you understand that
as a company it can only be as good as
the quality of people in talent able to
attract retain deploy develop then you
have the people component which is very
important you can only be as good as the
kind of people and talent you attract
and if you have this ownership culture
that says that this is our business so
therefore we should make decisions and
treat it as our own business then you
are in a much better place
you
I think this is the best kept secret in
our company is a dream people culture
because when you look at it it's so
common sense it's so obvious most
companies would think it goes without
saying and they would take it for
granted here then has a Busch InBev we
talk about it every day because we think
that's really what we stand for that's
so much of what we are as a company as a
group and therefore it's worth talking
about it all the time so I'll give you
an example if you don't buy into the
dream if you don't buy into the dream
that we're trying to build something out
of the ordinary something that's
best-in-class best beer company better
world a lot of the targets that we put
to our business on a yearly basic basis
don't make sense because they are very
tough targets the case if you want to
try it to be best what you do good is
not good enough so if you don't buy to
that dream in the first place you're
going to have a problem accepting tough
targets stretch targets but if you buy
into the concept that we're trying to
build something that's best in class
then of course we need to have stretch
targets because that's what we need of
course we need the best people not just
good or average people of course we need
to own this business because we're proud
of it and were part of it so this whole
thing kind of connects all the dots and
that's why we talk about dream people
culture all the time because that's what
in our experience merging with other
companies that was the only thing that
differentiator performs wise our company
from other companies